today we're talking about
industry-leading security ai solutions
study materials and summits i'm rhoda
and welcome to this week in cloud where
we serve you
the lowest latency news at google cloud
we defend your data against threats and
fraudulent activity using the same
infrastructure and security services we
use
for our own operations our goal is to be
the most effective partner as you
transform your business for a digital
world
whether your system is running google
cloud in other clouds or on-prem our
trusted cloud enables your digital
transformation while also supporting
your security transformation
check out the post for specifics of our
three new trusted cloud requirements
a secure platform that delivers
transparency and enables sovereignty
a proven zero trust architecture and
shared fate
not shared responsibility google cloud
offers
lots of products to support a wide
variety of use cases but
how do you even know where to start
don't worry we've got you covered
the four words or less google cloud
developers cheat sheet describes each
google cloud product in
four words or less if you're just
getting started this resource gives you
a quick overview of all that's available
to you on google cloud and if you're
more experienced it can be a great way
to identify new products that you might
want to learn more about
download the pdf of the latest version
at the links in the description or
on github gartner has named google a
leader in its 2021 magic quadrant for
cloud ai developer services
we believe this recognition is based on
gartner's evaluation of google cloud's
language vision
conversational and structured data
services and solutions
for developers this recognition is also
a reflection of the confidence and
satisfaction that customers have in our
products
from a cohesive ai stack for developers
to purpose-built ai solutions for
industry use cases
check out the blog post for more of what
gartner has to say
drawing on the experience of our
customers the google cloud born digital
summit will offer practical guidance on
building a resilient and scalable
foundation for great customer
experiences
over this half day event we'll highlight
proven best practice approaches to data
architecture diversity and inclusion and
growth
with google cloud solutions born digital
is an event for app developers
technology innovators and business
leaders who are disrupting the market
and shaping the future
check out the post to register and learn
more about the march 25 event
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud
you